[Musique]
c'est une bombe c'est une vraie bombe
éditoriale comme il pas beaucoup existé
à mon avis au 20e siècle je pourrais
dire qu'elle est presque unique parce
qu'elle va totalement
bouleverser le rapport des gens au
communisme et à la réalité soviétique en
tout
cas
c'est un livre absolument extraordinaire
la découverte d'une autre histoire parce
qu'à l'école à l'université on nous
apprenait une version de l'histoire et
soudain on découvrait qu'il y en avait
une autre dont on ne nous parlait pas à
laquelle nous devions accéder par
nous-mêm c'était la véritable histoire
de notre
pays
pour que les gens comprennent c'est des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
se mettent à lire ce livre au même
moment
et des polémiques d'une violence
complètement folle qui se déclenche sur
un objet
littéraire c'est un réc sa lutte et de
sa lutte avec le pouvoir avec les
confrères
avec les autorités avec lui-même pour
trouver le courage et c'est
[Musique]
magnifique
quelques mois avant sa mort Alexandre
sgenit nous avait raconté comment était
né dans le plus grand secret L'Archipel
du
[Musique]
Goulag un immense récit pour décrire ce
que fut le système concentrationnaire en
Union soviétique de 1918 à
1956 un livre unique nourri de
l'expérience de seénine dans les camps
et du témoignage de 227 zec les détenus
du
Goulag nous avions rencontré cell et
ceux que seit avait appelé les
invisibles en prenant de grands risques
ces femmes et ses hommes aujourd'hui
disparus avaent aidé l'écrivain à mener
à bien son travail sur
l'archipel dans des conditions Diges
d'un roman de John
leé chipel du Goulag transformé en
microfilm traverse le rideau de fer pour
arriver en France en
1968 les éditeurs Claude Durand et nikit
astruve n'ont plus qu'à attendre le
signal de solgenitin pour le
publier l'histoire de ce livre hors du
commun ne faisait que
[Musique]
commencer à cette époque ivaman jeun AG
de russe vient d'être nommé professeur à
l'université Nikita Stru un beau jour me
fixe un rendez-vous
mystérieux dans un café dans le centre
de Paris pas à l'université pas à
proximité d'imkapresse et là il me dit
voilà j'ai reçu un texte c'est une bombe
ce livre personne ne doit en connaître
l'existence il chercha un traducteur qui
puisse travailler dans le plus grand sec
et j'ai la légèreté
d'accepter en même temps je me
disais il est pas pressé de faire
laisser publier ce livre
donc on a du
temps derrière l'apparente insoucience
de cette fin d'été nous sommes en pleine
guerre froide lonide est à la tête
deurss et si rien ne le laisse présager
l'histoire de L'Archipel du Goulag va
basculer
Elena
chukovskayaa comme la
surnommé était une invisible l'une des
plus proches de
l'écrivain elle nous avait donné
rendez-vous chez elle et n'ait rien
oublié de cette journée
particulière je me souviens très bien
c'était fin
août
TER
auquel il avait été convi sans même
savoir qui était
mort et là il apprend que
[Musique]
c'étaitabethis on a essayé de savoir ce
qui s'était passé même s'il était
impossible de demander quoi que ce soit
par téléphone on ne comprenait vraiment
pas ce qui sétait
passe éta auur
disp point parul genénitine elle avait
tapé à la machine L'Archipel du Goulag
et en avait gardé un
exemplaire arrêté par le KGB elisabetha
subit des interrogatoires jour et nuit
et finit par avouer en détenir une
copie libérée elle rentre chez elle et
se
suicide on l'a appris en fait c'est une
longue histoire
c'est tout à fait par hasard la chose a
été su à leningrade et là-bas grâce à
une personne de confiance nous avons été
avertis que le livre avait été
[Musique]
saisi le manuscrit est désormais au
mains du
KGB il a tout de suite décid qu'il ne
fallait plus rien différer il fallait le
publier
ça s'est passé le 1er septembre et le 5
Alexandre a fait savoir en France qu'il
fallait publier
[Musique]
l'archipel en décembre3 ils publ en
russe et éé
un le livre est édité à Paris libraie
hisor l'immigration russe imka press
aussitôt les articles se multiplient à
la une des journaux du monde
entier à suivre les réactions dans la
presse on pourrait penser que L'Archipel
du Goulag est le premier livre qui
révèle l'existence des camp enunion
soviétique ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
on pouvait savoir beaucoup de choses sur
les camp en Union soviétique je suis
tombé un jour sur un livre en français
concernant les îles
il s'agissait des premiers camp en Union
soviétique dans les années 1920 à
l'époque de nombreux groupes de gauche
dans toute l'Europe connaissait
l'existence de ces camps parce que
certains de leurs camarades y étaient
détenus on pouvait lire des publications
sur ces camp à Berlin et à Paris ils
étaient tout à fait connus
[Musique]
entre 1918 et 1930 moi j'ai comptabilisé
au moins une trentaine de livres parus
dans le monde entier
concernant les méthodes d'emprisonnement
la répression les camp qui venaient de
s'ouvrir celui qui et cetera et donc il
est évident que on savait des choses
sauf que et c'est vrai c'est ça qui a
joué beaucoup est arrivé la Seconde
Guerre mondiale donc finalement à côté
du nazisme on a plutôt oublié le côté
goulag beaucoup de gens ne voulaient
rien savoir le sujet les mettait mal à
l'aise pour de nombreuses raisons bonnes
ou mauvaises parce que l'Union
soviétique avait été notre allié pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et qu'il
était gênant de dire que nous avions
détruit un monstre avec l'aide d'un
[Musique]
autre et puis effectivement jusqu'à
l'archipel du goulac tout d'un coup ça
fait un boouom parce que tout d'un coup
on découvre des choses qui semblait qui
avait été oublié pas vraiment oublié
parce que ça existait
on le savait mais on n parlait pas plus
exactement en décembre 19733 seul genit
n'est pas à Moscou auprès de sa femme
Natalia il se trouve à la datcha de son
ami l'écrivain Corneille
tukovski c'est làbas qu'il se trouvait
ce jour-là et c'est là qu'il a entendu à
la
BBC que le premier tome de l'archipel en
russe avait été publié en France il
espérait que le livre sorte pour le Noël
orthodoxe le 7 janvier comme convenu
mais il est sorti un peu plus tôt alors
il est parti aussitôt pour venir ici
dans cet appartement chez moi et toute
la soirée a été une
fête quelques jours plus tard les
premiers exemplaires de L'Archipel du
Goulag parviennent clandestinement à
Moscou
[Musique]
nous en avons reçu deux en même temps
par un canal ou par deux canaux
différents et par qui concrètement je ne
peux pas vous le dire parce qu'à
l'époque on gardait une certaine
discrétion celui qui n'avait pas à être
au courant on lui disait rien de
super de son côté l'organe central du
Parti communiste soviétique la Pravda ne
tarde pas à réagir et dénonce les cales
jitin qui servent les forces de la
réactions
impérialistes la confrontation s'annonce
violente savoir si j'allais en sortir
vainqueur je n'en avais aucune certitude
mais le fait que j'avais lancé un livre
qui allait leur porter un coup et qui
avec toute sa force allait lutter contre
eux ça je le
comprenais rapidement le KGB informe le
polte bureau l'organe suprême du pouvoir
du danger du livre
le compte-rendu d'une réunion au
kremelin témoigne de la réaction de
Léonide
brenef il s'agit d'un grossier panflet
antisoviétique solitine s'en est pris à
ce que nous avons de plus sacré à Lénine
à notre régime
soviétique il faut aujourd'hui décider
de ce qu'il convient de
faire
Alexandre en Allemagne de l'Ouest il
avait été appréendé Guer à son domicile
de Moscou il a été expulsé au our par
lesutorités de son pays leelin a recours
à une mesure sans précédent depuis
presque
demiècle sub le même sort que en
1929 l'arrestation puis l'expulsion de
l'écrivain renforce considérablement en
Occident l'intérêt
pour L'Archipel du
Goulag G sont entendre certain types
d'information à certain moment il ne
sont pas prêt à les entendre à d'autres
moments ainsi les gens n'étaient pas
prêts à entendre la vérité sur l'Union
soviétique dans les années 40 juste
après la guerre parce que la guerre a
été gagnée par une alliance avec Staline
25 ou 30 ans plus tard c'était très
différent c'était un moment où il était
clair que l'Union soviétique et l'Europe
de l'Est était un système
d'oppression bien entendu il y a aussi
l'aspect artificiel du choc ah on savait
pas
que le socialisme libérateur de
l'humanité avait créé un
bagne mais ça tient pas de bout
évidemment si on veut pas savoir on sait
pas aujourd'hui aussi si voulez si si on
veut pas savoir qui y a des gens affamés
dans le darrefour bah on le sait
pas on fait son petit guuleton
tranquille si on le
sait on tombe dans une certaine
intranquillité et sol génine nous mène
de façon profonde je pense à une
intranquillité
euh qui n'est pas du tout idéologique
qui est une
intranquillité
philosophique L'Archipel du Goulag
commence à ébranler les certitudes
pourtant on sait peu de choses sur ce
livre qui n'a pas encore été traduit on
parle de témoignages que des victimes
Gou on confié
à j'ai compris alors que le dest
m'envoyait ce dont j'avais besoin
l'archipel est venu à moi à travers ses
gens j'ai par la suite identifié les
plus importants d'entre eux ceux que je
considère comme les véritables
co-auteurs de
l'archipel bien sûr il ne comprenaient
pas ce que je faisais pourquoi j'avais
besoin d'e personne n'était au courant
de mon projet personne
eux c'est avec leurs émotions leurs
sentiments qu'il me donnent ces
informations je les recueillais avec
plaisir tout en me demandant comment les
intégrer à la structure du
livre fastenko était le plus alerte de
la cellule bien que vu son âge il fut le
seul à ne pouvoir escomter survivre à la
détention et recouvrer un jour la
liberté il me disait en me prenant par
les épaules c'est une chose que de tenir
pour la vérité toi pour elle tu te fais
détenir
ou bien il m'apprenait sa chanson une
chanson de bagnard s'il doit nous échoir
un jour de mourir au fond d'une mine ou
d'une prison cela se réfléchira sans
faillir sur les générations qui
resteront je le crois et puissent ces
pages aider cette croyance à
s'accomplir d'abord c'est une collection
de témoignages à peu près plus de 235 je
crois témoignages qui ont été rassemblés
par par ce génitine donc il y a c'est
une vision absolument globale du système
concentrationnaire hein de l'arrestation
des tortures de la vie dans les
camps des gens qui sortent des camps et
comment ils sont considérer enfin tout
c'est un c'est un tableau global de la
chose et ça personne ne l'avait vraiment
fait quand on lit le livre les trois Tom
on est excusez-moi on pas sous un roule
compresseur quoi on est on est on n pas
sous un roule compresseur on est on peut
pas sortir indème de cette lecture enfin
moi je suis pas sorti indème
personnellement on pu il n'écrit pas
seulement sur les camps il a écrit sur
les camps sur la guerre sur la
Révolution il écrit sur la façon dont
l'homme se comporte dans des situations
extrêmes ces situations extrêmes sont de
diverses natures cela peut-être la
guerre une maladie mortelle ou la
révolution c'est précisément de ça dont
il a parlé dans tous ses livres de la
manière dont les gens réagissent dont
ils se comportte dans ces situations
extrêmes ne fait pas que
décrire le le goulag il ne fait pas que
décrire la vie dans un camp se génitine
il s'intéresse à toute la machinerie qui
va conduire
les les des hommes libres à l'état de de
zec c'est-à-dire de de de prisonniers de
de camp de
concentration tout nouvel entrant après
avoir du piano à la section spéciale du
camp c'est-à-dire après y avoir donné
ses empreintes digitales se passait
autour du cou un fil supportant une
planchette sur la planchette on
composait son numéro et le photographe
de la section spéciale le photographiait
ainsi arnaché ces photos toutes ces
photos sont encore bien conservées
quelque part nous les verrons bien un
[Musique]
jour l'historien Alexandre Daniel
dissident à l'époque soviétique est l'un
des responsables de l'association
mémoriale qui travaille sur la mémoire
du
Goulag son père l'écrivain yulie Daniel
a été l'un des accusés du premier grand
procès de la dissidence en
1965 sa mère Larissa Bogoraz a été
condamnée à 4 ans de relégation en
Sibérie pour avoir manifesté en
1968 contre l'intervention soviétique en
Tchécoslovaquie
a réussi à faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire il a réussi la fusion
de deux courants de la mémoire l'analyse
de la terreur par
l'intellig et la mémoire populaire de la
terreur
c'estàdire la mémoire d'en bas les
témoignages direct d'une quantité de
gens sur la
terreur on appelle
aujourd'hui l'oire orale
[Musique]
cette structure générale les raisons
pour lesquelles les camp ont été créés
comment ils ont été créés comment se
comportaient les Gardiens et les
prisonniers la fameuse division entre
les prisonniers politiques et les
prisonniers criminels et leur relation
le sort des femmes et des enfants vous
savez qu'il y en avait aussi dans les
camps tout cela il l'a bien compris sans
avoir accès aux archives ni aux
informations officielles c'est un
document tout à fait
remarquable du côté du Parti communiste
français la réaction face à la
publication de L'Archipel du Goulag est
parfaitement conforme à la ligne du
crémelin hier soir à sainttoouin George
Marchet a évoqué l'affaire sol dans ce
livre l'auteur russe évoque des faits
que le communiste de l'Union soviétique
a lui-même dénoncé publiquement il y a
près de 20 ans et auquel il a mis un
terme mais le livre de
senitin constitue en même temps une
agression si violente si haineuse contre
le socialisme en 74 le Parti communiste
commence à être un peu sur le déclin il
a quand même été un parti qui avait plus
de 25 % des voix la Libération il ne les
a plus mais enfin il est encore puissant
et il réagit il y a une façon je dirait
frontal qui a consisté à dire B c'est
une nouvelle campagne
antisoviétique ça n'est pas intéressant
c'est même lamentable qu'aujourd'hui
encore on puisse revenir à de tels
propos et puis qu'il est capable de dire
on connaît tout cela vous n'apportez
rien de nouveau monsieur solgitin notre
parti a condamné il y a déjà une
vingtaine d'années le
goulag en fait le Parti communiste
français à cette époque n'a jamais rien
condamné il faudra attendre 1977 pour
qu'il reconnaisse l'existence du fameux
rapport krutchev présenté en 1956 au 20e
congrès du Parti communiste de l'Union
soviétique ce rapport dénonçait le culte
de la personnalité de Staline mais sans
évoquer les crimes de masse estimés 15
ou 20 millions de
morts le rapport kchev ne concernait que
le Parti communiste et les dirigeants du
parti injustement condamné il ne
décrivait pas l'ensemble du phénomène du
stalinisme ou du système soviétique qui
s'est bien sûr poursuivi SEV il y avait
encore des camps de prisonniers sous le
régime de kutchev et lorsque le grand
système de gouag a fini par disparaître
on a continué à arrêter des gens pour
des raisons
politiques ira plus gloire au parti cela
ne se reproduira plus ah les malins ah
les maîtres
platriers puisque cela ne se reproduira
plus il va de soi qu'aujourd'hui cela
n'existe déjà plus exclu pour l'avenir
et bien entendu inconnu dans le
présent ce Jine fait remarquer que le
goulac commence non pas avec Staline
mais avec Lénine lui considère que c
réalité concentrationnaire et
consubstantielle du communisme
affirmation insupportable pour les
communiste comme le soulligne Boris
jukov un représentant du kremelin
interrogé par la télévision française
pour moi c ennemi personnel pour les
soviétiqu aussi maintenant il veut
revenir làdus mais pas pour condamner
une fois de plus cette chose là mais
pour dire que c'est le système qui est
responsable que c'est Lénine qui a
installé le camp c'est insensé parce que
tout le monde sait que que Lénine céit
un grand don vraiment grand homme et un
noble d'esprit et et qui c'était un
grand HME
politique reconnaître que c'est sous les
nines que le goulag a commencé c'est une
ligne rouge que le Parti communiste
français ne veut pas
franchant
le 1er juin
1974 la publication en français de
L'Archipel du Goulag se produit dans un
contexte politique inédit à
gauche il y avait une gauche qui voulait
absolument se rassembler pour prendre le
pouvoir hein après des années de golisme
des années de
Pompidou donc il voulait prendre le
pouvoir donc il y avait il y avait un
programme commun qui était mis en place
avec les socialistes et et les
communistes donc évidemment on était
dans un contexte excessivement
particulier
au moment où au moment où l' où
l'archipel publ est publié en début 74
on est en pleine élection électorale
n'est-ce pas et nous avons en candidat
principal à gauche François mitteran
naturellement
mitan ne cherche pas à
provoquer le Parti
communiste après tout l'Union soviétique
c'est loin et son désir de de réussir la
présidentielle il est au contraire très
présent mitérant et prudent donc on est
dans une bataille politique dans
laquelle honnêtement franchement l'Union
soviétique le C le Goul ça n'existe pas
parce queon est sur un autre
planète de son côté
ivaman le premier traducteur de
L'Archipel du Goulag est nommé attaché
culturel à l'ambassade de France à
Moscou avant de partir nitu demande mais
écoutez maintenant que vous serez sur
place à Moscou est-ce que vous
accepterez de servir de relais entre sol
genénitsine et son épouse et puis leurs
amis il s'agissait essentiellement de de
transmettre du courrier des lettres
enfin pour maintenir le contact tout ça
se faisant bien entendu à l'insu de mon
ambassade ça va s'en dire dans un Moscou
digne d'un film d'espionnage yvaman
devient un invisible au service de
solgenénitsine avec et beaucoup d'autres
l'archipel ne tarde pas à entrer
clandestinement en URSS malgré la
surveillance du
KGB la romancière
ludmaa appartient à une famille marquée
par la répression et les camp elle vit
aujourd'hui en exil à
Berlin nous avons commencé à recevoir
des livres grâce à des étrangers de
passage qui les faisit passer par leur
ambassade par la valise diplomatique
nous avion ASI accès à genre de
littérature c'était risqué vis-à-vis de
mon ambassade parce que la devise
c'était ne nous brouillez pas avec la
République des sovietes en revanche les
Américains faisaient cela ouvertement
donc on savait que à l'ambassade des
États-Unis les il y avait des caisses de
livres en langue en russe bon les livres
interdits et
ça les le personnel de l'ambassade des
États-Unis le faisait ouvertement et eu
ils avaient tout à fait l'accord de
leurs autorités ça c'est évident une
guerre d'influence que confirme l'ancien
directeur de la CIA Robert
Gates vous saz c'est ce que nous avons
fait en Union soviétique durant la
guerre
froide avec très peu de technologie nous
avons fait passer des millions de livres
comme L'Archipel du
Goulag
Alexandre podrabineek a été une grande
figure de la
dissidence deux fois jugé pour
diffamation du régime soviétique il a
passé 5 ans et demi en prison dans un
camp et en relégation Sibérie il vit
toujours à
Moscou j'ai lu l'archipel du Gou
quelques mois après sa
publication il a tout de suite commencé
à arriver en Union soviétique en 1974
d'ailleurs avec un ami nous en avons
fait plusieurs copies on nous avit passé
un exemplaire publié à Paris ce qu'on
appelait le tamisd on l' photographié et
on ti
exemplaires l'endroit où nous avons fait
ça nétait plus un appartement c'était
une maison de fou il y avait des photos
partout des piles de photos sur la table
et dans tout l'appartement ça sentait le
révélateur et le
fixateur
c'estpo on faisit tout
nousmême
[Musique]
je n'étais pas seulle à le lire nous
étions plusieurs c'était des feuilles
tapé à la machine à écrire qui n'était
pas attaché les unes aux autres on
lisait une feuille et puis on la passait
à quelqu'un
d'autre ce n'est pas seulement
l'archipel que nous avons lu de cette
façon mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
livres de cette auteur et d'autres
auteurs les cuisine chez nous elle
n'étaent pas grande mais c'est dans ces
cuisines pleine de monde qu'on se
retrouvait et qu'on lisait c'était une
particularité très intéressante de la
vie soviétique en fait nous vivions en
petite communauté bien soudée c'est ce
qu'on appelait les cuisines de
Moscou olga sakova est poétesse essiste
son vre d'abord diffusé dans le circuit
Sam à l'époque soviétique ensite été
publi à l'étranger elle habite toujours
à
Moscou cé une édition sur papier très en
un se t lesuds pass re en exigeant qu'on
le r un jour ou de après on don ce livre
pour très peu de temps ça
j'aicver
parce qu'il était de petit format et on
avait trouvé une boîte de gâteau dans
laquelle on le cachait ou dissimulait
pour le passer à un ami au téléphone on
disait viens prendre le gâteau c'était
nos méthodes de
[Musique]
conspiration je pense qu'il n'y a pas un
pays au monde à aucune époque où la
parole imprimée avait une telle valeur
par que pour tel livre on pouvait perdre
son travail ce qui m'est arrivé
d'ailleurs ou même être envoyé dans un
camp comme cela est arrivé à
d'autres c'était vraiment une occupation
très
dangereuse
Ivanovo ce n'est pas une prison de
transit très renommé mais interrog donc
ceux qui ont été enfermés durant l'hiver
37 38 la cellule 21 devait abriter 20
détenus or ils étaient
on ne distribuait pas la nourriture à
chacun des détenus mais par groupe de
10 si l'un des 10 mourit on le fit sous
le chal et on gardait jusqu'à ce que le
cadavreest ainsi pouvaiton continuer à
toucher sa ration pendant quelques
temps G on all en prison pas pour
avoirit circuler ce de livr pour lesoir
fariqu faiton
ça ça pouvait encore passer mais si
quelqu'un se mettait à le reproduire
notamment avec des moyens techniques là
on faisait tout pour lui mettre la main
dessus et là les gens all en
[Musique]
prison régulièrement la presse
clandestine dissidente rend compte
d'arrestation et de condamnation pour
avoir reproduit ou diffusé l'archipel du
Goul
mon grand-père a été envoyé dans un camp
à sa femme la belle- mère de ma mère a
aussi été dans les camp et dans la
famille de ma mère beaucoup de personnes
ont été victimes de la
répression certaines ont été
exécuté la sœ de mon grand-père elle
dans lesamp de
la d'une manière générale je connaissais
bien tous les aspects du sujet mais
solgenitin a réussi à créer un panorama
qui réellement couvre toute cette
période de la terreur de
1917 à
1953 l'ampleur l'immensité de ces crime
bien sûr était quelque chose
d'inimaginable ce qui fait que d'une
certaine façon
ma vision du monde s'est transformée
ainsi que ma compréhension de ce qui se
passait dans le monde et dans notre
[Musique]
pays l'édition française de L'Archipel
du Goulag arrive en
librairie immense succès premier tireur
euh 550000 exemplaires en France un des
plus gros que j'ai jamais
connu le le le peu après voilà au début
de l'été on en était à 850000 ou 900000
exemplaires la totalité des trois
volumes en France a fait plus d'1200000
exemplaires ce sont les Français et les
Allemands qui ont été les premiers à le
publier et les Américains sont venus
après mais le livre un énorme succès aux
États-Unis aussi il a fait 3 millions
d'exemplaires au total avec 30 à 40
traductions dans le monde le livre a
atteint à peu près les 10 millions
d'exemplaires la façon dont le public a
été demandeur dès le début dès le
premier jour montre que que ça venait à
son
heure bien sûr nous ne perdions pas
espoir ce que nous avions vécu serait un
jour raconté tôt ou tard en effet la
vérité finit par être dite sur tous les
événements de l'histoire
mais il nous semblait que cela ne
viendrait pas avant longtemps que la
plupart d'entre nous seraient mort avant
et qu'il faudrait que la situation a
profondément
changée moi-même qui me considérait
comme le chroniqueur de l'archipel et
qui écrivait écrivait sans relâche je
comptais peu voir la chose de mon
vivant pour une partie de la génération
de Mai 68 la lecture de L'Archipel du
Goulag débouche sur une véritable prise
de
conscience cette génération 68 le
communisme m manière soviétique c'était
le vieux monde d'ailleurs dans les 68 un
des slogans c'était court court camarade
le vieux monde est derrière toi hein
donc pour pour eux c'était le vieux
monde cette génération post 68 elle
était complètement admirative c'était
quand même incroyable de le penser
d'ailleurs parce que c'était de malempie
quelque part de Mao du maoisme pour eux
c'était pas un problème d'attaquer
l'Union soviétique et de dénoncer le
goulag
s là il y a deux gauches qui vont
s'opposer c'estd qu'il y en a une qui va
qui va accepter Soline mais plus que
l'accepter d'ailleurs qu' va
devenir la partie qui le défendra le
plus et le plus brillamment je pense et
une autre partie qui va le rejeter et
qui va pas vouloir l'entendre parce
qu'en fait elle pressent que l'écouter
l'entendre le lire
c'est c'est
mourir les deux jeunes intellectuel les
plus actifs dans la défense de ce
génidcine c'est André gluxman et Bernard
Henri leville Andr gluxman une très
belle formule à ce sujet il dit les cand
c'est un bon point de vue sur le
marxisme c'est-à-dire ça nous permet de
lire la la substantifique moelle du
marxisme puisque vous étiez
correspondant de l'humanité vous avez
renseigné les lecteurs français de ce
qui se passait en l'Union soviétique des
camps de concentration vous en avez
parlé vous avez un seul de vos articles
qui en parle ah on ne connait pas les
chifres bien sûr on connait pas les
chifres on connait pas non plus les
chifres dans less parce que vous
connaissez pas vous n'avez rien lu de ce
que j'ai écrit par cons si si il y avait
une belle apologie par exemple qui lui
ses concurrents il les mett il les
mettai dans ses camp moi mon père quand
il l'archipeloulag c'est une révolution
intérieure
c'est c'est un moment fondamental c'est
une fracture dans l'histoire à la fois
d'une vie personnelle
et dans l'histoire collective c'est
peut-être ça la philosophie ou
l'émission la part de vérité nous donne
une idée de ce qu'était le débat à
l'époque ce jour-là autour de la table
entre autres Michel fou Maurice Clavel
guilard r André gluxman et on parle de
se genine et de l'archipel du
goulement dans les universités
françaises et dans les milieux
bien on discute du socialisme on discute
des moindres virgules de Marx tout le
monde sait après tuer après les liges
que une virgule à droite ou à gauche ça
détermine le sens de l'histoire cela dit
il est évident que les mêmes gens ne
veulent pas et systématiquement ne
veulent pas lire ce genénit vous savez
la meilleure que j'entend quoi ça c'est
l'humanisme oh le trisème tome du Goulag
que c'est long que c'est long que c'est
long voilà évidemment 50 millions de
morts ça fait une liste longue voà ou et
oui et dans les librairies de gauche ça
ne se vend pas et oui c'est vraiment le
basculement d'une génération en plus qui
a plus cru qu'aucune autre dans le mythe
révolutionnaire et qui tout d'un coup se
retrouve face à l'archipel et qui donc
vit l'archipel comme en plus une
déflagration intérieure fondamentale bah
je sais pas moi là je crois que c'est
quand même vraiment assez simple c'est
que seul genitine c'est une philosophie
parce que je je considère que c'est un
philosophe c'est une philosophie qui
fait pas plaisir quoi la grandeur de
L'Archipel du Goulag c'est que on y
trouvera pas une 11ce d'illusion nulle
part bon c'est quelqu'un qui ne m
jamais depuis leur exil Alexandre et
nataliaitine utilise les droits d'auteur
générés par l'immense succès de
l'archipel pour alimenter leur fond
d'aide au prisonniers
[Musique]
politique tous les droits d'auteur sur
ce livre à l'époque où j'étais encore à
l'étranger je les ai donné à notre fond
nous avons beaucoup aidé ici en Russie
en Union soviétique d'abord les prison
qui trouv alors en détention et puis
plus tard nous avons apporté notre aide
aux anciens prisonniers à ceux qui
étaient déjà
âés fond d'aide donna aux gens la
possibilité de se sentir
libre car il savaient que leurs proches
et leur famille ne seraient pas dans la
misère si on les arrêtait que quelqu'un
s'occuperait d'eux le viendrait en aide
et les laisserit pas tomber
savoir qu'il en serait ainsi était très
important à cette
[Musique]
époque qui s'est installé dans le
Vermont aux États-Unis reste persuadé
qu'il reviendra un jour dans son
pays au milieu des années 80 mir
gorbatev tente avec la pestroï une
profonde réforme du système
soviétique autorise alors une certaine
liberté d'expression dont va bénéficier
se
[Musique]
génine il estimait qu'il ne pouvait pas
revenir tant qu'on aaurait pas publié
l'archipel du Goulab et cela pour une
raison très
simple d'abord on l'a exilé à cause de
L'Archipel du Goulag c'est cette
publication qui en a été la cause
deuxièmement des gens ont été envoyés en
prison à cause de l'archipel pour avoir
lu l'archipel en secret des gens ont été
dans des camps et lui il va rentrer on
l'a expulsé à cause de l'archipel et lui
va rentrer comme si de rien nétait non
d'abord libérer ses gens et publier le
livre en
1989 profitant de l'affaiblissement de
la censure à Moscou la revue novimir
publie des extraits de
l'archipel le rédacteur en chef de
novimir à l'époque zigin était un homme
tout à fait remarquable il était prêt à
faire ce pas courage et il l' fait parce
que publier l'archipel écrit par un
traître à la patrie c'était encore plus
terrible que de publier 1962 le récit
d'un petit instituteur de la ville de
ryzan plusieurs maisons d'édition vont
ensuite assurer la diffusion de
L'Archipel du Goulag dans un plus large
public l'un si
est alors à bout de souffle elle va
disparaître 2 ans plus
tard quand l'archipel du G a été imprimé
chez nous avec de gros tirages dans les
années 90 il est apparu que ces
information n'av pas sur mes
compatriotes l'effet colossal qu'elles
avaient eu sur moi à l'époque en
1974 l'archipel du Goul a sû modifié la
conscience de notre société pas autant
que je l'attendais peut-être que mes
attentes étaient exagérées j'avais
l'impression qu'après avoir lu ce livre
les gens allaient aussitôt rejeter le
communisme le système totalitaire et son
idéologie mais ça ne s'est pas passé de
manière aussi radicale que je l'avais
penser nous avions l'impression et
beaucoup de gens le disaient à l'époque
qu'on souhaitait tout simplement oublier
tout cela ça ne concernait pas seulement
mais aussiam et toute cette thématique
on était convaincu je ne sais pas
pourquoi que tout cela était terminé à
jamais et que jamais plus nous ne
serions confrontés à une machine de
répression absolue telle qu'elle est
décrite dans ces conditions à quoi bon
tout cela nous allons vivre bien dans ce
monde nouveau c'était l'état d'esprit
général mais tout le monde ne voulait
pas oublier ce passé créé à la faveur de
la pérestroïa avec l'aide du prix Nobel
de la Paix Andre sakarov l'association
mémorial se donne pour mission de
préserver la mémoire des victimes des
répressions politiques en
URSS elle fouille les archives met au
jour des charniers et au fil des années
dresse une liste nominative inachevée de
3 millions de victimes une manière de
poursuivre le travail entamé dans
L'Archipel du
Goulag comme il l'avait prédit seitine
est de retour en Russie
en juillet 1994 il atterrit à Magadan la
capitale de la Colima en
Sibérie je m'incline devant la terre de
la Colima où repose des centaines de
milliers sinon des millions de nos
compatriotes
supplici
dans les années 90 souffle un vent de
liberté il n'y a pas que le retour de
Seine mmorial travaille librement c'est
après l'arrivée au pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine en 2000 que tout change la
réécriture de l'histoire devient un
enjeu politique il a commencé à limiter
l'accès aux archives à ce qui pouvait
être publié en Russie c'est quelque
chose qui l'intéresse depuis longtemps
le refus de reconnaître plus longtemps
que cette histoire qui
Ann
je
ilietion c pourraitevenir il n a pas que
la difficulté d'accès aux archives
mémorial fait l'objet de perquisition la
justice enquête sur ses activités l'un
de ses
collaborateursmit est envoyé dans un
camp sous des prétexes
fallcieux tout cela sur fond de
répression généralisé
[Musique]
plusieurs opposants comme Anna
Politkovskaya et Boris nemzov ont été
assassinés d'autres ont été contraint à
l'immigration ù sont derrière les
barreaux comme Alex Navalni condamné à
19 ans de
camp en février 2022 4 jours après
l'invasion russe en Ukraine la Cour
suprême à Moscou prononce la dissolution
de mémorial coloréade du prix Nobel de
la
Paix morial a cré une image mensongère
de l'URSS en la présentant comme un état
terroriste l'association mémoriale a été
fermée le centre sakarov a été fermé
leurs énormes archives ont été caché on
les a sauvé comme on a
pu qui avait mis au jour des charniers
de l'époque stalinienne est en prison
c'est-à-dire que le vrai travail sur ce
passé est devenu un crime puni par la
loi et bien l'ennemi numéro 1 de Poutine
c'est mémorial l'ennemi numéro 1 de
Poutine c'est ceux qui documentent les
crimes du stalinisme l'ennemi numéro 1
de Poutine c'est ceux qui poursuivent
l'œuvre de L'Archipel du Goulag mémorial
c'est l'organisation qui doit être
détruite pour que le grand projet
totalitaire de Poutine puisse avoir lieu
et mémorial c'est l'esprit de solénicine
mémorial c'est l'esprit de l'archipel du
boulag et aujourd'hui quand il y a un
procès contre mémorial quand il y a la
dissolution de mémorial en réalité ce
qui se passe c'est quoi c'est qu'on
brûle
[Musique]
l'archipel parfois on essaie de nier
l'ampleur de la terreur la
min mais en gros le fait même qu'il y a
eu la terreur ça personne
le aujourd'hui voilà à peu près le genre
de réaction assez répandu que j'ai
observé lors de discussion sur la
terre et bien oui il y a la terreur et
alors il y a juste eu de 500000 à 700000
personnes exécuté pendant la Grande
Terreur bon et
alors il y a eu la liquidation de la
classe paysane bon et alors en revanche
à l'époque l'État était
puissant aujourd'hui des gens qui disent
ça il y en a autant que vous voulez et
dans ce sens l'archipel est impuissant
contre ça contre ce rejet des traditions
humanistes de la culture
russe
[Musique]
l'archipel du gouag lui pose un problème
particulier car il montre le rôle
horrible négatif et destructeur joué
dans l'histoire russe par le
KGB et Poutine lui-même en tant que
produit du KGB et son empire incarne
d'un sorte de renouveau
KB Russie je peux imaginer qu'il Souha
Liv
[Musique]
pas tempépression
estadement
prison
25scr trouve grand soutien dans les livr
de
desk et même dans le
[Musique]
MI lors de son procès Vladimir caramour
lit ostensiblement le livre de se le
chîn et le
veau dans une interview il a confié
cette année j'ai lu ou relu beaucoup de
livres j'ai eu enfin la possibilité de
lire L'Archipel du Goulag en entier et
avec soin c'est un livre que tout le
monde doit lire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce livre est aujourd'hui
aussi contre le
régime parce qu'il parle de l'homme et
d'un état terroriste du destin de
l'homme dans un état
terr il a quel temps j'avau ce livre et
puis je viens de reprend j'aiensé mon
dieu c'est tout simplement ce qui se
passe
maintenant
et la
suite chaque fois que je l'ouvre je vois
que la force de ce livre est
intact chaque année des touristes se
rendent au î Solovki là où a été créé en
1923 le premier camp du
Goulag
la mémoire des prisonniers y est
toujours présente de ceux qui sont morts
d'épuisement de ceux qui ont été fusillé
et jeté dans une fausse
[Musique]
commune mais quel sens donner
aujourd'hui à cette mémoire celle de
L'Archipel du Goulag de plus en plus
occultée croire que cet archipel est
uniquement réservé l'Union soviétique
telle qu'elle a été pendant 70 ans c'est
évidemment réduire l'archipel du gouag à
pur et simple témoignage il est
témoignage mais il est beaucoup plus que
cela et donc il est valable pour la
Russie
d'aujourd'hui Matis moutandis ce n'est
pas la Russie stalinienne mais il y a
des traits qui sont communs il est
valable pour nous en partie pour
d'autres parties du monde c'està-dire
c'est un grand livre
qui non seulement apporte sa
grande son tsunami de vérité au moment
où il est écrit mais qui est encore
valable pour aujourd'hui et le restera
ce que je dirais à à quelqu'un qui me
pose la question simplement pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut lire
Soline mais parce que ce que Soline
dénonce existe encore tant que cette
violence existe et que ce déniis existe
et bien ce génicine restera d'actualité
et donc si je conseille de le lire c'est
pas simplement parce qu'il faut
comprendre l'importance du livre à une
époque donné mais parce qu'en fait cette
époque n'est pas encore révolue et qu'en
fait elle le sera jamais c'est ça qu'on
apprend et ça c'est c'est
[Musique]
c'est incroyablement frustrant parce que
ça veut dire que
le livre il est puissant mais en faitut
le réécrire à chaque fois et c'est ça
son
histoire cette histoire ne disparaîtra
pas avec cell et ceux qui l'ont
vécu une nouvelle génération s'est
emparée de cette
mémoire est un jeune réalisateur russe
2019 il est revenu sur les lieux du
Goulag pour en tirer Kima lieu de
naissance de notre peur ce film
documentaire de plus de 2 he mis en
ligne sur sa chaîne YouTube a dépassé
les 28 millions de
vues en
2022 accusé par le kremelin d'être un
agent de l'étranger Yu a été contraint
de quitter la
Russie
[Musique]
tant qu'il n'existera pas dans ce pays
d'opinion publique
indépendante il n'existe aucune garantie
que tout cet anéantissement sans cause
de millions d'hommes ne se répètera pas
à nouveau qu'il ne recommencera pas
n'importe quelle nuit chaque nuit cette
nuit
tenez celle qui va suivre la journée
[Musique]
d'aujourd'hui